well hello everyone my name is Victor I
come from the new rule University where
I'm in the middle of my PhD studies with
the professor professor fearo and
professor del Roca and I'm very happy to
be here today with such a big audience
and they are really hope to convince you
that nowadays we can easily develop a
multi-class classification algorithm
this spark on really big datasets so
what we are going to to do today is them
to speak about what's parties what the
dupe is really briefly not a deep dive
then we will see several algorithms
which work or does not work well or
perform well on the spark and the Duke
in general and explain why we'll see an
example for real data set with the Quad
Cities all the code is available at my
github repository so you can go and
enjoy yourself after the lecture em and
they'll share some my experience from
the past years of using Hadoop in a real
production information systems so that
let's just let me just ask you how many
of you are familiar with a dope with
messages concept okay so about half of
the audience so let me just briefly
explain what it is so it will put us all
on the same page well probably the best
example to explain well imagine that you
have a lot of data you have bread is a
different vegetables tomatoes onions in
the every node every computer on the
left side stores its own chunk of data
and your mission is to prepare a
sandwich on your way to work so you can
ask for every worker every node to slice
its own chunk of data and the chunks are
absolutely different they are not shared
and this is the map operation which is
followed by reduce operation which
combines or displaced chance into one
great edge
so this is what is basically it happens
in the behind the scenes in the dope and
in Sparks and so before we go into spark
let's see what I do basically well I do
have several notes which have lots of
chunks of data and then we build the
data by building I mean the Train model
you have too many times we need to place
over the data again beginning again in
an interaction of training and named in
the process of adaptively updating of
the ways of your model or when you need
to train your parameters so what is
happening is that between every
iteration all the data is read from the
disk some computation is performed the
data is written back to the disk then it
is read again it's written again read
again read again and then there are lots
lots of reads and the right operations
on the harvest which is actually very
inefficient and costly
so these things work really really slow
so in response to this low predict move
this part came out and the most sense of
content is part is the algae which is a
resilient distributed data set so in
contrast to Hadoop what represents part
is that this data also is in very smart
cache system so the data is cached it
with the form some alteration in the
seven intermediate results it is not
written that immediately to the disk and
between the iterations of the training
the data is kept inside the memory and
this resultant really magnificent test
data which sometimes is even order of
magnitude okay some more benefits about
spark well it it operates in a great
computation rate so those of you who are
familiar with the tensor flow or dynamic
way of thinking when you compose
function functions one on top of another
and then ask them to be executed that's
exactly what is happening is the spark
and the you have a several languages you
can use when you program if you really
call the injure you can go for Scala
which is the web backend of spark itself
all the immediately libraries arrive in
Scala only done in Java which has the
benefits of strongly typed language and
all the later it arrived in Python the
machine learning library which is the
Emma Lib also supports the our language
which I absolutely hate if I three
people who learn Scala they said that
there is a price entrance price to learn
Scala but once you want it it's really
fantastic from my experience in most of
the case of Python is fine enough well
it's fine to own programs very hard to
maintain like always so let's just go to
an example of a whole world program in a
a spark imagine we have a really big
text file which is such it's so big it
is split on several nodes from several
hard disks and we want to simply count
each word the number of occurrences for
each word so imagine a federal
computation graph first you read the
file which is sorting this path into
some text variable which is actually our
are the generamon to the resilient
distributed data set I will explain in
the minute what it is exactly and then
you do the publish your computation
graph which actually a list processing
paralegal those of you who are familiar
with scheme or list this is exactly what
is going on and our output will be the
following one so will several
two-dimensional table right two columns
each word how many times it appeared in
a file so let's go line by line and the
examine what is happening here
by the way those are the RPGs that is
text and counts are both like you can
think of them as a handler to a file
which actually is stored on multiple
servers and for from a user program a
perspective of you it's just a variable
very simple and the thing about added is
is that they're actually immutable list
and compare the computation graph
symptoms are lazy so you must call like
compute when you are ready so let's
explain this because it's quite quite a
complicated to understand at first
glance so imagine our text file contains
the following line mix represented by
data meter at the bula opposite Ramat
Gan
so it immediately I read this file into
the tech started in the file became
actually released the list code text in
each element is believed is the line
from the file so receive a list with two
lines well for simplicity let's assume
that every part of the list is stored in
another node inside the our adult
cluster this is the first line here and
the second line here on the second node
once I wrote text both flatmap and gave
this lambda expression actually I
declare a lazy computation which will
split every element inside the list with
a space flat map I remind you allows for
multiple outputs for every element so
the first element the associate uncle is
the five element and the second element
outputted this line this is the flat map
okay in the minute we clicked
click road met lung the world one
actually we going to from the
concatenation of one to every board
inside this list and we get this so we
have now at least a long list of pairs
where in each pair the key is the world
and the volume is one that you just
added right when you call reduce by team
transformation what you get is you get a
combination by this scheme and all the
elements inside the list are combined
according to the first element and then
processed with this lambda expression we
should our case that sums the value
element of the pair so we had three
times the pair at and one so at the end
of this process we get a that appears
three times well just the to convince
you and to make you believe that is very
very simple let's see how it really
works in the cluster for a minute well
that's something that prepare before
let's say okay so what if you see here
now is a notebook in a data bridge where
I just put the same value just on let me
run it for a minute
well this it and then how did they get
the file here
adjust the bottom dragon drug has some
kind of Apple definition you can drag
and drop a file here so absolutely
simple what's happened behind the scenes
just all the mechanism of distributing
computation we just talked about so hope
you believe me so it's really simple
tick tick tick so but we are about the
fight data here right so we are
interested in machine learning and
training and models so what they do you
have to do with that so let's go to data
sets so all the models and the trainings
in spark operate with the same kind of
are disease and the the elements that
you should put inside the IDS are of the
type labeled point labeled point is a
built-in type inside spark and it
receives two over two parameters the
first one is the label that is the class
inside the training set and the second
adjust the list of features and each and
every of the models from the algorithms
we have received this kind of the recent
RDG well I'll tell at the end of my
presentation that there is some other
mechanism of the linking for those of
you for SQL ninjas here but I am
personally I don't love it so much but
will they talk about it one in at the
end so something that is very
interesting also it which algorithms can
actually exploit the distributed
structure of spark and the algorithms
that really benefit from spark are those
who make as little as possible any
passes on the data for example news
based algorithm that can pass the data
only once too
and old official on the data they need
to conversion to compute its parameters
rather than algorithms that make many
subsequent shell passes and reads of the
data so actually named base or the
clustering algorithms which can split
the space of their data works in the
real world and much much faster than not
else part random beggin of course
because you can split both the instances
themselves anew you can split the space
of the features if you have to lots of
them and each subspace will be trained
in its node random first probably my
favorite algorithm when I don't use the
nrnl so it's my personal choice to go to
I really love it and they of course
linear regression and this is why this
is because spark and loop can multiply
matrices really really efficiently so
linear regression also works very well
and very fast even when you have data
set that are huge terabytes of data and
then not only lots of instances but also
lots of features so if you have I don't
know million two fishes it also works in
scales and the Delta imagine think about
it so which algorithms we don't like
them on spark and on a book well neural
net you have to do many passes over the
data you need to read the data again and
again in the game for each Apple we
don't like it swam we don't let logistic
regression and other boosts for the same
reasons basically yes well actually this
little [ __ ] there are two extension on
spark who do attempt to perform a neural
net implementation which is distributed
they do split the space of the weights
which are being trained both in
computation of the
target and loss and bottom the
propagation but they don't need to share
a lot of information between the notes
to compute the back propagation itself
so it's not that of a favorable
Britain's although you do have some
benefit you are right a so now let's get
to some more complicated example which
is the panel data set
what is the panel that is quite a big
data set but it's a small enough to run
on a notebook that we get from a
community in a community distribution of
the data breaks it only one point seven
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what we have here we have a fifty two
attributes the duke every missing values
and they do have a multi-class
classification problem what the problem
is the problem is imagine if every
person with different variables by
variables I mean it's called mu which is
the inertial measurement unit like they
measure the heart rate the temperature
of the person in which position the arm
or the leg is its acceleration different
different features and what we need to
classify is what this person is doing
currently if he is the person lying
sitting crying running speaking in front
of amazing audience on high data ironing
driving the car or playing football and
then in this data set we have 18
different activities that we need to
classify a person for one of them there
are ten subjects ten different people
who volunteered for this pact and then
we have the data so let's see how we
actually do it well first just to get a
feel on how this data looks like when
you open the CSV of the fire of their
dataset
well first you have the temperature then
you have the accelerometer or a first if
of the time
don't need to get rid off actually some
people say we don't but I think we don't
then we set the class the label we have
the heartrate and measurements of three
different variables and each variable
consists of this is 17 the fields within
the temperature deceleration and they
pay attention there are like seven
fields that the data after it was
collected they concluded it is invalid
and should not be used so our vision
here even more complicated we need to
get rid of some of the features we need
to complete the non values which are
missing and we need to classify after
all these huge data set features by this
point of time is distributed about
distributed among several nodes ok so
what we are going to do is first will
read and clean the data will live only
the relevant features that are valid
will compute the average of those
features as our strategy for the missing
values you can also for example shoot on
film with the most
computations which we'll see in a minute
how we can do it because I reminder this
list are immutable when you process them
we need to somehow the in distributed
way to compute an average and it's not
that we go and then we'll finally train
and evaluate the model and we'll see how
easy it is to just declare the base
random forest in the yogic tradition we
spark sorry actually a logistic
regression now just me just human spark
implements one versus all strategy for
multiply specification so it actually
trains number of fluxes minus one by the
classifiers when which don't compete one
against the pendulum okay so so first
let's clean the data well a romantic
we've starting to build our computation
graph first we have the list of the line
become and we compose a function which
slices the data which is splitted very
space and then it removes all the
indices that were declared invalid by
the data set provider and the response
we get the expression actually which
describes once computed delete all of is
the relevant features clear right okay
so but just a minute I just thought okay
what about side effects is what about
average what about me
what they do we want to do is how we can
compute it once we can't really change
and access the list themselves they are
do this so there is a mechanism which
which is called an accumulator which is
a distributed counter and then you must
operate an in in what is called X ages
but let's tell it associative and
commutative way that means the items you
operate on can be switched in the order
and this doesn't matter how you group
the items between the nodes this is what
associative and commute
it means and it's a regard aim so let's
say an example first I will declare a
list of pairs where each pair is an
accumulator initialized to zero and the
converter can be accessed right can be
written only by a worker and can be read
only by master program which is called
the driver which can access it after all
the workers finished their update so
what what is happening here is that I
build the computation graph user but now
a call which is called an sparking
action which is the computation graph is
actually executed it's not just declared
as an expression but the code is
actually run well what I have here is I
just go over each line if I see that the
value there is not man that is the value
is not missing
we found the feature and we also count
it what you want to do at the end in the
Dragon program want to ask the value of
this accumulators after divorce and and
there counts and compute the average as
simple as that and in just less than 10
lines all this magically happened
distributed and very very fast and very
intuitively to read right well I really
love it I don't know where I don't get
this impression from you now ok
this method runs parallel by all the
waters we store each chunk of the data
when you call the for each on the line
30 from the driver program it calls all
the workers which are all the knows
whose store their relevant part of the
data to perform this one to think about
the bulletin is it
Coleman to all the workers is opposed to
the RTD where they store only their
relative part so when they so now you
can think and understand why it should
be associative and commutative because
you don't know in which order the salmon
the comment will arrive to the main
place right okay so what you can see
here the judge here you just sum it in
it settles in the workers then this is
why it is parallel and here when you
access it you have to sit by value and
this is performance actually not
parallel but in the driver main problem
okay you see the value okay next you
want to fill the missing value so we
compute the continues our computation
got graph construction the line sliced
data and then again one more list map
processing with film it enviros to go
over each value inside each line in if
there is none we just assign it with the
correct a feature middle well another
interesting thing to pipe arc is that
they the models when they are decimal
pay attention this is the labeled poem
structure which should be fed into the
training algorithm well the interesting
are not interesting actually annoying
part of training the DES classic should
be encoded from 0 to n minus 1 plus
number so what I do here at the top of
the slide is that I encode the classes
actually values to 0 to 17 and from what
it was previously in the CSV file itself
ok so let's say think look at the
computation graph the just was wrong
here first you have the data structure
you going to slice the data then if you
fill the missing values and at some
point we just run the graph in all the
composed functions here which operate
on the distributed distributed restored
CSV are executed well finally let's
build the the models the models were
going to build the three one there are
much more gradient boosted trees are
also supported even a neural networks
are supported I don't see the exact
benefits of this model so we'll need
them now
well the first of the simplest a simple
is that you just ran need based training
that's it after this line we have a
trained model which was trained
distributed Li each node the current is
the currencies with the name assumption
and the model was combined the second
lines the first one makes the
predictions and the second one computes
the errors well it's pretty
straightforward
first to predict under the features not
on the label and the second one we
filter out those elements that you are
not predicted correctly and divided by
the number of complete tested and you
get there oh sorry I think I didn't
understand what you just asked well when
I played with it and I tried the tote I
done so are you okay okay so what's this
again and I'm gaining what is
interesting here is that the test metal
projects are also distributed image I
imagine the test is very very large and
it stores by I don't know how many
different nodes of workers in us also
computed and predicted to land this one
just to make it float nothing else okay
my favorite a random forest well it's
say you see it have quite impressive
hyperparameters interface actually there
are even more harder parameters that you
can name a tune in the random forest but
they say
of course you can actually you must say
the number of classes you have to
specify explicitly the number of trees
you have to specify the a criterion
according to which the split is computed
wither is it a genie or entropy you can
also step to the classifier the strategy
of how much features are used in the
randomization if it's out oh by the way
it is the square root of the number of
features for each string and the rest is
exactly the same as the in the name base
by the way there is also a you can also
set the number of beans which is to how
many things you can divide in the values
of the features when you're building the
trees in the forest I think it is I
think it is when the okay so okay so I'm
finished yes yes but well as I think of
it it it's have a they should have a to
me like to two points where double teams
randomized the first one is the the
samples and the second and the features
and they do want to exploit the fact
that the data is distributed for
building the parallel equally in a
parallel way all the trees the
participate in the first so I actually
allow it that it is a distributed I
don't know whether it has a seed a
actually I actually don't know but
you hesitated well is go go ahead and
try to run circuit normal ten terabytes
of CSV file probably it is in Vegas
probably it is I really told it I tried
several times and the performance was
almost the same between different trance
so I didn't aim may be the model itself
was not the same right it I don't know
well about the Beast exhibition you're
right it was created by the nature to
deal with the binary classification and
it exploits the wonders of saw strategy
so once we wrote here that the number of
positive 18 actually asked behind the
scenes for the first part we're asking
is to build 17 classifiers 17 binary
classifiers each time one class versus
all the rest and basically the
prediction and the error computation in
the self is the same okay so just to
convince you to cut how is it is let's
see the notebook you just use in this
example in TPP keep it close it look
okay so here is the code I just wrote
lately what we have just seen in the
same workspace on data breaks you can
get about the way completely free these
are my files so it's really easy by the
way before we finish I want to show
something else you can also install
spark without disability near only a
favorite machine and just that the code
we just solve the world count right and
just channel runs beautifully also now
when it is not distributed also this
detected process is now emulated behind
just on a computer we get all the counts
so far so you see it's really simple
very easy the only difference is the
despair context which distributes the
work between the notes here must be
explicitly specified and then on Python
data books you get it the real one which
is not a fake but a fake news but a real
distributor in May ok so first all the
quantity we suggesting present on my
github account you are more than welcome
to go and see it in addition to Pamuk
data set I have implemented there the
training of a blog word embeddings if
you know what it is and some a coke last
link algorithm of item to user for
recommendation systems or you're more
than welcome to she'll use it well I
hope I didn't manage to convince you it
is really really easy
it's really fast it's where and when
people I talk to about Spartan adult and
here Hadoop laughter it's a hell how can
we even start with it so no no it's
really easy just go and do it quick and
dirty so to make a samsung word before
it goes to production just to learn and
play with it very simple well another
tool that I tried in the IDM decided to
put it here because it also has a
built-in notebook mechanism called
Zeppelin which is ultra cool and very
easy if the Hortonworks they have a
hadoop image with a very good support
for Mac with a VirtualBox and with a
VMware for st. OS works beautifully in
ok we last nothing I want to tell you is
the spark and spice Park especially well
that's all the things in Python it's
very easy to code it it's very hard to
maintain the administration once you go
to production
and not the implement of algorithm is an
actual profession in a dopant spark have
really many atoms they have an entire
ecosystem which something is very
tempting for example the HBase but if
you consider to put it in a production
system which have to be in a very high
uptime be careful some of them are real
beasts like the adult itself in what we
seen today was an Emmy lib a library for
machine learning which operates with
lists in a laser computation graphs mode
actually there is from a year ago or
something like this that ml library
instead of Hamlet which is supported by
spark won't eat the thing about it is it
operate and data frames we shall
actually see it with like a tables which
are read into the spark mechanism and
the those of you who are more familiar
with this kind of working with SQL a
more than welcome to go and try it and
the Samson I also learned in the hard
way
when you have lots of text which you
need to process and to put another
production it don't rush to the DuPont
to spark do yourself a favor and they
consider other distributed a mechanisms
which are scalable for example a solar
or elasticsearch the work dutifully even
if you have not only unstructured text
but also text with ease which is
partially structures with lots of fields
it works well for many cases not that's
it that was the last interfere so
questions
nothing non-numerical sorry reason why
use the in range nothing enumerate just
personal preference
okay thank you
[Applause]